Katrina: 他们说可以出去了
Katrina: They said we can go out now.
Katrina: 那把肉拿出去
Katrina: So, take the meat out.
Tasha: 我们正好有一个盘子
Tasha: We just happen to have a plate.
Tasha: 没那个然后可以把那个盘子拿来
Tasha: If not, we can just use that plate.
Tasha: 放10个蛋糕就行
Tasha: Just put 10 cakes on it.
Lucia: 盘子这个盘子good
Lucia: This plate, this plate is good.
Tasha: 对正好有个盘子刚被我们抽出来了
Tasha: Yeah, we just picked out a plate.
Lucia: 棒棒
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay.
Jake:大成功
Jake: Great success.
Lucia: 所以所以所以外面是可以了是吗
Lucia: So, so, so, is the outside ready?
Jake:呃对
Jake: Uh, yes.
Jake:算是可以了
Jake: Pretty much.
Jake:温度起来了
Jake: The temperature is up.
Jake:火还没完全着完
Jake: The fire isn't fully burnt out yet.
Jake:可以开始考了就是
Jake: We can start grilling now.
Lucia: 我那个杯子在哪里来
Lucia: Where's my cup?
Tasha: 杯子
Tasha: Cup.
Tasha: 杯子杯子
Tasha: Cup, cup.
Lucia: 哦我怎么老是找不到东西呢
Lucia: Oh, why do I always lose things?
Lucia: 放10个
Lucia: Put 10 of them.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Tasha: 12个也行
Tasha: 12 is fine too.
Tasha: 10个吧不知道
Tasha: Maybe 10, not sure.
Lucia: 行万一一会到的多了再放
Lucia: Okay, if we need more later, we can add more.
Lucia: 哎呀我放12个吧因为刚好排三排
Lucia: Oh, I'll put 12 because it fits nicely in three rows.
Jake:好看对挺好
Jake: Looks good, yeah, very nice.
Lucia: 强迫症发作
Lucia: My OCD is kicking in.
Jake:我来把芒果给干掉
Jake: I'll finish up the mango.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:我放在哪了找个碗
Jake: Where did I put it? Get a bowl.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Tasha: 你可以每个里面放3块3
Tasha: You can put 3 pieces in each.
Tasha: 嗯铺个底
Tasha: Yeah, just lay a base.
Tasha: 我看铺个底要多少个好吧
Tasha: I'll see how many we need for the base, alright?
Katrina: 就是这种
Katrina: It's like this.
Tasha: 这么多吧
Tasha: This many should be fine.
Tasha: 大概123 哈哈
Tasha: About 123, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈行我还是数数123456
Lucia: Hahaha, alright, let me count, 123456.
Tasha: 好就铺个底就行这样子
Tasha: Just a base layer, that's enough.
Lucia: 78九个这么多呀
Lucia: 78, nine of them, that's a lot.
Tasha: 9-10个吧
Tasha: About 9-10 pieces.
Lucia: 行好嘞
Lucia: Alright, got it.
Lucia: 它有的会两片粘在一起
Lucia: Sometimes two slices stick together.
Lucia: 所以就占的面积小一些
Lucia: So it takes up less space.
Tasha: 要不来倒主厨
Tasha: How about we let the chef pour it?
Jake:哈哈我
Jake: Haha, me?
Jake:我怎么敢
Jake: How could I dare?
Jake:哎倒什么呀
Jake: Pour what?
Tasha: 就把它倒进去就行
Tasha: Just pour it in, that's all.
Jake:好好行
Jake: Alright, sure.
Jake:我试试倒多少啊
Jake: How much should I pour?
Jake:三分之几
Jake: How much, a third?
Tasha: 倒个七八分满就行
Tasha: Pour it until it's about 70-80% full.
Tasha: 但是要 12个
Tasha: But we need 12 pieces.
Jake:三分之
Jake: A third...
Tasha: 你要倒均匀点吗
Tasha: Do you want to pour it evenly?
Lucia: 咦多了
Lucia: Oops, too much.
Jake:好那我就慢慢倒
Jake: Alright, I'll pour slowly then.
Tasha: 不着急要等这个烤出来他才能到
Tasha: No rush, we need to wait for this to bake first.
Jake:嗯哦
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Tasha: 他才能进
Tasha: Then it can go...
Tasha: 进下一锅
Tasha: Into the next batch.
Jake:懂了
Jake: Got it.
Jake:那我还是干芒果
Jake: I'll just handle the mango.
Katrina: 哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒
Katrina: Da da da da da da da da da da da.
Jake:这芒果不软的
Jake: This mango isn't soft.
Lucia: 虽然不软
Lucia: 但是我感觉它看起来有啊
Lucia: 好像已经有点
Lucia: 稍微有点那个氧化了一样
Lucia: It looks a bit oxidized.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:有水果刀吗
Jake: Do we have a fruit knife?
Tasha: 要不要洗一洗
Jake:用菜刀也行吧
Jake: We can use a kitchen knife, right?
Tasha: 嗯要求不要太过分
Tasha: Yeah, don't be too picky.
Alice:上面有几根
Alice: There are a few on top.
Shure: 上面还有俩
Shure: There are two more on top.
Jake:这不过分吧
Jake: This isn't too much, right?
Jake:有水果捞切芒果
Jake: We have fruit salad to cut the mangoes.
Tasha: 差不多吧
Tasha: It's almost enough.
Tasha: 进入完全不讲究状态
Tasha: Going for a completely casual approach.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What's this?
Katrina: 咖啡豆啊
Katrina: Coffee beans?
Tasha: 呃巧克力
Tasha: Uh, chocolate.
Lucia: 巧克力啊没事不用对不起
Lucia: Chocolate, it's okay, no need to apologize.
Katrina: 哦哦对不起
Katrina: Oh, sorry.
Katrina: 巧克力
Katrina: Chocolate.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我
Katrina: Hahaha, I...
Katrina: 我的生活常识太匮乏
Katrina: My common sense is really lacking.
Lucia: 哇这巧克力好香啊
Lucia: Wow, this chocolate smells so good.
Lucia: 可以吃一个吗哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Can I have one? Hahaha.
Tasha: 可以啊他就是纯巧克力黑巧58
Tasha: Sure, it's pure dark chocolate, 58%.
Lucia: 要先吃一片吗哈哈哈
Lucia: Want to eat a piece first? Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈我不要
Tasha: Haha, I don't want it.
Lucia: 宇轩要先吃一片吗
Lucia: Yuxuan, do you want to eat a piece first?
Katrina: 我尝一个
Katrina: I'll try one.
Lucia: 喂你吧要不哈哈哈
Lucia: Shall I feed you? Hahaha.
Katrina: 好的你喂我吧
Katrina: Okay, you feed me then.
Lucia: 健康要先吃一片吗
Lucia: Jianqiang, want to eat a piece first?
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 我就不喂你了
Lucia: I won't feed you.
Lucia: 自己可以给你倒出来哈哈
Lucia: You can serve yourself. Haha.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 哎呀我再来一片
Lucia: Oh, I'll have another piece.
Jake:这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Jake:这叫什么呀
Jake: What's this called?
Tasha: 一定要认准这个牌子
Tasha: Make sure to recognize this brand.
Tasha: 百丽
Tasha: Belle.
Tasha: 天呐
Tasha: Oh my god.
Jake:嗯确实不太好端
Jake: Hmm, it's really hard to hold.
Lucia: 哈哈哈他突然文盲哈哈哈哈不不不
Lucia: Hahaha, he suddenly became illiterate, hahaha, no no no.
Tasha: 不愧是高材生
Tasha: Truly a top student.
Tasha: 说话就是这么有水平
Tasha: That's how eloquent they are.
Tasha: 我来切吧
Tasha: Let me cut it.
Tasha: 你去忙那个
Tasha: You go handle that.
Tasha: 好我先跟你
Tasha: Okay, I'll be with you.
Tasha: 你菜板忙
Tasha: You handle the cutting board.
Tasha: 洗了吗怎么感觉这么脏
Tasha: Did you wash it? Why does it feel so dirty?
Jake:加点洋葱味问题不大
Jake: Add some onion, it's not a big deal.
Lucia: 啊哈哈哈
Lucia: Ahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha, yeah.
Tasha: 哈哈哈这菜板怎么这么脏啊
Tasha: Hahaha, why is this cutting board so dirty?
Tasha: 你这菜刀洗了吗
Tasha: Did you wash the knife?
Jake:菜刀洗了
Jake: The knife is washed.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 板子那就再那啥一下呗
Jake:板是蒜和洋葱
Jake: The board has garlic and onion.
Jake:对哇不要蒜
Jake: Yes, no garlic.
Lucia: 哇不要蒜
Lucia: Wow, no garlic.
Lucia: 蒜沾到水果上面味道很大的
Lucia: Garlic on fruit makes it taste really strong.
Lucia: 洋葱可能还好一点
Lucia: Onion might be a bit better.
Tasha: 你太过分了
Tasha: You're too much.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 把水果也从洗了
Tasha: Wash the fruit too.
Jake:好好水果我也洗一洗
Jake: Okay, I'll wash the fruit as well.
Lucia: 没事幸好它还没切开
Lucia: It's fine, luckily it hasn't been cut.
Lucia: 要蒜味要沾到水果上真的特别难消掉
Lucia: If the garlic flavor gets on the fruit, it's really hard to get rid of.
Lucia: 就是你就会吃到那个味道
Lucia: So you will taste that flavor.
Jake:哈哈好的
Jake: Haha, okay.
Lucia: 就是葱不是葱
Lucia: The scallion isn't really scallion.
Lucia: 蒜瓣西瓜吃过吗
Lucia: Have you tried garlic watermelon?
Lucia: 哈哈哈蒜瓣西瓜对我
Lucia: Hahaha garlic watermelon, really.
Jake:蒜瓣西瓜就是把蒜给绞西瓜汁里
Jake: Garlic watermelon is just blending garlic into watermelon juice.
Lucia: 没有就有一回
Lucia: No, just once.
Tasha: 就是切切的刀上面有蒜味
Tasha: The knife used to cut had garlic flavor.
Lucia: 我们家里忘记对我们家切过蒜的刀
Lucia: We forgot to clean the knife we used for garlic.
Jake:哦哦切刀刀上哦
Jake: Oh, the cutting knife, oh.
Lucia: 忘记了然后直接切的瓜
Lucia: Forgot and then cut the watermelon directly.
Lucia: 然后那个味道特别可怕
Lucia: And then the taste was really awful.
Jake:用什么东西泡呀
Jake: What do you soak it with?
Tasha: 这肉
Tasha: This meat.
Jake:我来到吧
Tasha: 您来
Tasha: You try.
Katrina: 这怎么洗嘞
Katrina: How do you wash this?
Tasha: 这个可以
Tasha: This is okay.
Lucia: 嗯我试试看
Lucia: Hmm, I'll give it a try.
Tasha: 您要吗
Tasha: Do you want it?
Jake:我可以要
Jake: I can take it.
Katrina: 我好像不会洗青菜
Katrina: I think I don't know how to wash vegetables.
Katrina: 就是
Katrina: Just...
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina: 我的认知里好像没有洗青菜这个选
Katrina: I don't think washing vegetables is an option in my knowledge.
Tasha: 就他可以
Tasha: He can do it.
Tasha: 阻断他流
Tasha: Block it from flowing.
Lucia: 生菜确实一般
Lucia: Lettuce is indeed average.
Lucia: 可能都直接在这放一下好了
Lucia: Maybe just put it here for now.
Katrina: 择
Katrina: Pick.
Lucia: 哎小心吃会不会那个会不会烫
Lucia: Hey, be careful, will it burn?
Lucia: 我也不知道
Lucia: I don't know either.
Lucia: 咱要不把它
Lucia: Should we
Lucia: 都掰开吧
Lucia: break them all apart?
Lucia: 找个盘子
Lucia: Find a plate.
Katrina: 然后还要干嘛来着
Katrina: Then what else do we need to do?
Katrina: 哦还要拿两个杯子
Katrina: Oh, we also need two cups.
Jake:是不是有点太保守了
Jake: Is it too conservative?
Lucia: 把盘拿大点的
Lucia: Get a bigger plate.
Lucia: 盘子这盘
Lucia: This plate.
Lucia: 不过这盘子还没用过
Lucia: But this plate hasn't been used.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: Then...
Jake:我先少弄点啊
Jake: I'll start with a small amount.
Tasha: 啊好
Tasha: Ah, okay.
Jake:好我保守一点保守一点
Jake: Okay, I'll be conservative, conservative.
Lucia: 就它吧
Lucia: This one then.
Lucia: 啊那这又要再放一下先
Lucia: Ah, then this needs to be put aside for now.
Lucia: 这怎么搞
Lucia: How should we do this?
Jake:哈哈确实
Jake: Haha, indeed.
Jake:这个多吗
Jake: Is this too much?
Tasha: 这正常吧
Tasha: This is normal, right?
Tasha: 我觉最高就这么高就行了
Tasha: I think it should be just this high.
Jake:诶诶诶诶诶诶别
Jake: Hey hey hey, stop.
Jake:别动啊别动啊诶
Jake: Don't move, don't move, hey.
Jake:我可能会了
Jake: I might get it now.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Tasha: 有合关发牌
Tasha: There's a deal with the cards.
Tasha: 有杨老师在线切蛋糕液
Tasha: And Jake is cutting the cake online.
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Tasha: 嘿嘿嘿是吧
Tasha: Hehehe, right?
Jake:对哎感觉不错
Jake: Yeah, it feels pretty good.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:挺好玩
Jake: It's pretty fun.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 好玩多玩会
Tasha: It's fun, let's play a bit more.
Tasha: 哎这个会不会太过分了
Tasha: Hey, isn't this a bit too much?
Jake:没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake:我怕最后不够了
Jake: I'm just worried there won't be enough in the end.
Lucia: 你干了什么
Lucia: What did you do?
Jake:还好还好就是呃呃尽量让他均匀
Jake: It's alright, it's alright, just try to make it even.
Tasha: 尽量让他均匀
Tasha: Try to make it even.
Jake:但是可能没那么均匀
Jake: But it might not be that even.
Tasha: 你看第一个和这个均匀吗
Tasha: Look, is this one even with the first one?
Jake:哎一会再补一补啊补一补
Jake: Ah, I'll fix it in a bit, fix it in a bit.
Lucia: 你做了什么伤天害理的事
Lucia: What horrible thing did you do?
Jake:补一补补一补
Jake: Fix it, fix it.
Jake:就是这个分配不均
Jake: It's just uneven distribution.
Tasha: 这个这个这个
Tasha: This, this, this.
Jake:这个哈哈哈
Jake: This, hahaha.
Tasha: 不患寡患不均
Tasha: It's not about scarcity, it's about inequality.
Lucia: 不患寡而患不均
Lucia: It's not about scarcity but inequality.
Jake:对就是现在这既既寡又不均
Jake: Yeah, now it's both scarce and unequal.
Lucia: 弃寡又不均
Lucia: It's both scarce and unequal.
Tasha: 这个放在烤箱面前
Tasha: Put this in front of the oven.
Tasha: 会不会把它水分给烤了
Tasha: Will it dry out all the moisture?
Lucia: 我刚也在这么想
Lucia: I was just thinking that too.
Lucia: 但是我好像暂时没找到别的地方
Lucia: But I can't seem to find another place for now.
Lucia: 我打算快点洗
Lucia: I'll wash quickly.
Tasha: 这个厨房就这么小对
Tasha: This kitchen is so small, right?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 咱们人比较多
Lucia: There are quite a few of us.
Lucia: 这厨房有点太小了
Lucia: This kitchen is a bit too small.
Lucia: 这么大厨房我觉得两三个人还行
Lucia: In a big kitchen like this, two or three people would be fine.
Lucia: 再多就东西会放不下
Lucia: Any more and there's no place to put things.
Tasha: 还有十几分钟这我就烤好了
Tasha: In another ten minutes, this will be done baking.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 那咱外面的进度咋样
Lucia: How's the progress outside?
Jake:呃进度
Jake: Uh, progress.
Jake:不知道啊反正5分钟之前进度是0
Jake: No idea, but five minutes ago the progress was zero.
Lucia: 说明他们进度与指数函数性增长
Lucia: It means their progress is growing exponentially.
Jake:是的是是这么回事
Jake: Yes, that's the case.
Jake:是一个呃
Jake: It's a, uh...
Tasha: 维护秀是吧
Tasha: Maintenance show, right?
Jake:应该就是就火点着了
Jake: It should be just lit.
Jake:然后就可以开始了
Jake: Then we can start.
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Ah, OK.
Tasha: OK火点着了
Tasha: OK, the fire is lit.
Lucia: 火点着这是个原爆点
Lucia: The fire is lit, this is the ground zero.
Tasha: 是个原爆点是的
Tasha: It's the ground zero, yes.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 废物
Shure: Useless.
Jake:刚刚特意买了一个啊不一桶酒精
Jake:然后全洒上去了然后没了
Lucia: 呃时外面风太那啥了吗还是
Jake:那个碳比较难点
Jake: That charcoal is a bit tricky.
Jake:碳质量一般
Jake: The quality of the charcoal is just average.
Katrina: 应该用那种蜂窝
Katrina: We should use the honeycomb kind.
Katrina: 蜂窝的那个
Katrina: The honeycomb one.
Jake:应该是
Jake: Probably, yes.
Lucia: 它接触氧的面积会比较大一点
Lucia: It has a larger surface area to contact oxygen.
Katrina: 耶
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 只剩一只筷子了
Katrina: There's only one chopstick left.
Jake:听起来是这样
Jake: Sounds like it.
Jake:一只筷子
Jake: One chopstick.
Alice:一开始烤
Alice: Start grilling at first.
Katrina: 哎我们只有这几双筷子
Katrina: Hey, we only have a few pairs of chopsticks.
Shure: 油低下去是吧
Shure: The oil drips down, right?
Jake:我也好奇那个他什么情况
Jake: I'm curious about his situation too.
Lucia: 哎还行吧
Lucia: Eh, it's alright.
Jake:对啊可好了
Jake: Yeah, it's good.
Tasha: 你是刚才就是再分配了一下吗
Tasha: Did you just redistribute it?
Jake:对对对再分配
Jake: Yeah, yeah, redistribute it.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 二次分配
Tasha: Redistribution.
Jake:哈哈哈是的
Jake: Hahaha, yes.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Jake:扶贫现在是
Jake: Poverty alleviation now.
Jake:看看好现在全面脱贫
Jake: Look, now complete poverty alleviation.
Jake:哈哈哈可以吧
Jake: Hahaha, it's fine, right?
Katrina: 哈哈哈笑死
Katrina: Hahaha, laughing to death.
Lucia: 好家伙
Lucia: Oh my gosh.
Jake:怎么样和谐
Jake: How about harmony?
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay
Lucia: 可以非常好
Lucia: Yeah, very good
Tasha: 你看有的很好
Tasha: Look, some of them are really good
Jake:啊还是有一些先富的人是吧
Jake: Ah, there are still some people who got rich first, right?
Katrina: 了
Katrina: Yeah
Lucia: 哎我觉得里面的这些叶子很干净
Lucia: Hey, I think the leaves inside are really clean
Tasha: 不
Tasha: No
Tasha: 不是你看这上面有很多气泡看到了吗
Tasha: No, look, there are a lot of bubbles on top, see?
Tasha: 啊就这样子
Tasha: Ah, just like this
Jake:哦那我每个都打一会
Jake: Oh, then I'll give each one a little hit
Tasha: 就是因为你可能弄得太低了
Tasha: It's because you might have done it too low
Tasha: 然后他的气泡就会产生
Tasha: Then the bubbles will form
Tasha: 这样子会导致他很多空心的就不太
Tasha: This will cause a lot of hollowness, which is not good
Shure: 翻过来应该会好一点
Shure: Flipping it over might help
Jake:就不太明白哎
Jake: I don't really get it
Tasha: 哎这个
Tasha: Hey, this
Jake:这个这怎么了
Jake: What's wrong with this?
Jake:这太少了啊
Jake: This is too little
Tasha: 啊没事
Tasha: Ah, it's okay
Jake:没事还是有低保户
Jake: It's okay, there are still low-income households
Tasha: 嗯对你把有气泡的就这样子震一震
Tasha: Hmm, right, just shake the ones with bubbles like this
Lucia: 什么历史遗留问题是吧哈哈哈
Lucia: Some historical leftover issues, right? Hahaha 社会问题
Shure: 行看着吧
Shure: Okay, just watch
Jake:哈哈哈对是地质疑的问题
Jake: Hahaha, yes, geological issues
Tasha: 不然不然它不好吃就不够松软
Tasha: Otherwise, it won't taste good, not soft enough
Jake:哦我每个都摔一摔吧
Jake: Oh, I'll give each one a little shake
Jake:嗯那这个我怎么加上呢
Jake: Hmm, how should I add this then?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Katrina: 有一种早期那种围炉取暖的感觉
Katrina: There's a feeling like those early days of warming by the stove
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh
Lucia: 要遵循事物的发展规律吗
Lucia: Follow the laws of development, right?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 很爽的人
Shure: Such a cool person
Tasha: 这个还要再洗一下
Tasha: This needs to be washed again
Katrina: 很爽特别这边还特别安静
Katrina: So cool, especially since it's so quiet here
Lucia: 哈怎么了
Lucia: Haha, what's up
Lucia: 你以为我个人专业
Lucia: You think I'm a professional
Jake:哈哈哈专业太专业了
Jake: Hahaha, you're too professional
Lucia: 个人简历的专业是白写的哈
Lucia: My resume's professionalism is all for nothing, haha
Jake:这个你要不写个报告吧
Jake: Why don't you write a report
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 没少咋地
Shure: Didn't miss anything
Jake:哈哈怎么了
Jake: Haha, what's up
Shure: 再烧一会
Shure: Let it boil a bit longer
Tasha: 没事没事没事
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay
Jake:撒了
Jake: Spilled it
Tasha: 等会再用
Tasha: We'll use it later
Tasha: 这部分谁都不要碰
Tasha: No one touch this part
Jake:那谁敢碰啊
Jake: Who would dare touch it
Lucia: 这玩意我先给他们端出去吧
Lucia: I'll take this out to them first
Lucia: 要出去吗
Lucia: Should I take it out
Lucia: 来看一眼
Lucia: Come take a look
Lucia: 别别菜叶子吹干了
Lucia: No, no, the leaves will dry out
Tasha: 干什么呢干什么呢干什么呢
Tasha: What are you doing, what are you doing
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Tasha: 我要干嘛
Tasha: What am I supposed to do
Jake:你要干嘛
Jake: What are you supposed to do
Lucia: 这个菜现在用得到吗
Lucia: Do we need this vegetable now
Lucia: 如果暂时用不到我就先放回去
Lucia: If we don't need it now, I'll put it back
Lucia: 一会再拿出来
Lucia: I'll take it out later
Jake:哈哈哈对不起对不起
Jake: Hahaha, sorry, sorry
Shure: 也可以
Shure: That works too
Katrina: 你可以放桌上呢
Katrina: You can put it on the table
Lucia: 桌上我怕外面灰大一会就
Lucia: If I put it on the table, I'm afraid it'll get dusty
Katrina: 啊那放里面吧
Katrina: Ah, then put it inside
Lucia: 那煤能给它敲碎吗
Lucia: Can you break up the coal?
Lucia: 我感觉那么大一块确实不太不太好
Lucia: I feel like a big chunk like that isn't good.
Tasha: 哎我靠
Tasha: Oh my gosh.
Lucia: 那啥
Lucia: So...
Jake:不能这么干是吧
Jake: We can't do it like this, right?
Tasha: 呃没必要
Tasha: Uh, no need.
Jake:哦好行
Jake: Oh, okay then.
Tasha: 可以了可以了
Tasha: It's fine, it's fine.
Tasha: 干嘛呢接下来
Tasha: What's next?
Jake:不不有气泡
Jake: No, no, there are bubbles.
Tasha: 去切去
Tasha: Go cut it.
Jake:真有气泡
Jake: There really are bubbles.
Tasha: 真没必要了
Tasha: Really, no need.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈这为什么感觉有
Jake: Haha, why does it seem like there’s...
Jake:有红的颜色
Jake: ...some red color?
Jake:是这个油
Jake: Is it this oil?
Tasha: 巧克力可能溶溶了一些可以了
Tasha: The chocolate might have melted a bit, it's fine.
Jake:你看这个是气泡吧
Jake: Look, these are bubbles, right?
Lucia: 这哪里有红的
Lucia: Where's the red?
Lucia: 您绝对色感也太好了吧
Lucia: Your color perception is amazing.
Jake:哈哈哈哈有这种夸赞吗
Jake: Hahaha, is that a compliment?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈你是不是想说这么明显
Lucia: Hahaha, are you trying to say it's so obvious?
Lucia: 哈哈哈是啊
Lucia: Hahaha, yeah.
Jake:不是不是我说有这种夸赞
Jake: No, no, I mean like this kind of praise.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Jake:不是就是
Jake: No, it's just...
Lucia: 真是一种夸赞
Lucia: It really is a kind of praise.
Lucia: 你学画画很厉害的
Lucia: You're really good at drawing.
Lucia: 会哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:好这么回事
Jake: Okay, I get it now.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:可能是我这个眼线的反射
Jake: Maybe it's the reflection of my eyeliner.
Jake:我怎么切怎么切
Jake: How should I cut this?
Tasha: 怎么切直直接切就行
Tasha: Just cut it straight.
Jake:好我就切
Jake: Okay, I'll cut it.
Jake:行我直接切
Jake: Alright, cutting it straight.
Lucia: 另外这棵菜哎呀
Lucia: And this dish, oh dear...
Lucia: 我都在想要不等他们进度再再来点
Lucia: I was thinking maybe we should wait for their progress and then add more.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 我再洗
Lucia: I'll wash it again.
Lucia: 菜这东西
Lucia: About this vegetable...
Jake:但是还没必要
Jake: But there's no need yet.
Lucia: 如果洗了就不能就不太能放了
Lucia: If we wash it, it can't be stored for too long.
Lucia: 万一是吧
Lucia: Just in case, you know.
Lucia: 我们退一万步讲
Lucia: Worst case scenario...
Jake:对万一今天他就打不着了哈哈哈
Jake: Yeah, what if it doesn't work today, hahaha.
Lucia: 今天晚对哈哈
Lucia: Right, tonight, haha.
Jake:退一百步就是哈哈哈
Jake: Take a hundred steps back, hahaha.
Tasha: 我买的我买的
Tasha: I bought it, I bought it.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Tasha: 烤箱温度计
Tasha: The oven thermometer.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 这个吗
Lucia: This one?
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my...
Tasha: 竟然真的是
Tasha: It really is.
Lucia: 这个是不是要洗啊这个对对对
Lucia: Does this need to be washed? Yes, yes.
Tasha: 不是要洗啊
Tasha: Doesn't it need to be washed?
Tasha: 是吗对对对
Tasha: It does, yes, yes.
Tasha: 虽然很危险
Tasha: Though it's quite dangerous.
Lucia: 哎呀就喜欢这种没有油的东西
Lucia: Oh, I just love things that aren't greasy.
Lucia: 一旦沾上油就可难洗老难洗
Lucia: Once there's oil on it, it's so hard to clean, really hard to clean.
Lucia: 我靠我不会又弄衣服了吧
Lucia: Oh no, did I get it on my clothes again?
Jake:我感觉好像不
Jake: I don't think so.
Alice:main twition
Alice: main twition
Jake:好像切了出来怎么没什么肉啊
Jake: It seems like after cutting, there isn't much meat.
Shure: 牛太牛了
Shure: This is amazing.
Lucia: 因为皮上沾的太多了
Lucia: Because there's too much stuck on the skin.
Alice:炭烧透了
Alice: The charcoal is well done.
Jake:我来
Jake: Let me do it.
Tasha: 给你们洗个碟
Tasha: I'll wash a plate for you.
Jake:我来我来研究研究
Jake: Let me take a look at it.
Lucia: 不是您这个的正确打开方法
Lucia: No, that's not the right way to open it.
Lucia: 哎sorry啊
Lucia: Oh, sorry.
Tasha: 不用sorry吧
Tasha: You don't need to say sorry.
Tasha: 给您洗个碟
Tasha: I'll wash a plate for you.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 您想怎么切就怎么切
Tasha: Cut it however you like.
Lucia: 就是就是
Lucia: Exactly, exactly.
Lucia: 你这个的正确打开方式
Lucia: That's the right way to open it.
Alice:哎你这是碳
Alice: Hey, that's charcoal.
Lucia: 现在变成了这样
Lucia: Now it's turned into this.
Tasha: 不是这个里面没盒吗
Tasha: Isn't there supposed to be a box inside?
Lucia: 我给你我给你演示一下啊哈哈
Lucia: Let me show you how to do it, haha.
Jake:有有有还没搞定呢试一下啊
Jake: Yeah, yeah, it's not done yet, let's try it.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:哈哈哈好很正确
Jake: Haha, very good, very correct.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈你知道吗
Lucia: Haha, you know what?
Jake:哈哈哈我也来正确一下
Jake: Haha, let me get it right too.
Lucia: 打开包成了这样的
Lucia: When you open the package, it looks like this.
Jake:好好好会了会了我也会了
Jake: Okay, okay, got it, I got it too.
Tasha: 我也会的
Tasha: I can do it too.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 这个应该不是你切的问题
Lucia: This shouldn't be your problem to solve.
Tasha: 就有的芒果它就是皮比较容易粘肉
Tasha: Some mangoes just have skins that stick to the flesh.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:就应该这么打开
Jake: It should be opened like this.
Shure: 也有可能是这个碳太低了
Shure: It could also be that the carbon is too low.
Lucia: 对秉承着我们不浪费的原则
Lucia: Yes, sticking to our principle of not wasting.
Lucia: 就也可以先这样吃一下
Lucia: We can eat it like this first.
Lucia: 然后那部分的用来用来当馅
Lucia: And then use that part for filling.
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Lucia: 外面是不是有什么进展了
Lucia: Is there any progress outside?
Lucia: 我好像听见了碗筷的声音
Lucia: I think I heard the sound of dishes.
Lucia: 给孩子饿成啥了
Tasha: The kids must be starving.
Jake:在敲是吧
Jake: They're knocking, right?
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 他们可能只是单纯的就是在把碗筷
Lucia: They might just be moving the dishes.
Jake:走位哈哈哈接
Jake: Moving around, haha, got it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈从一个地方搬到另一个地方
Lucia: Hahaha, from one place to another.
Jake:好吧好吧虽然打不着继续走位
Jake: Okay, okay, even if it doesn't hit, keep moving.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay.
Lucia: 我当时想问能不能把那个碳
Lucia: I was thinking of asking if we could break the carbon.
Lucia: 比如说怎么着给它敲
Lucia: Like, break it up a bit.
Lucia: 敲碎一点
Lucia: Smash it a bit.
Jake:不要切到手呀
Jake: Don't cut your hand.
Jake:那我这个会这个知道
Jake: I know how to handle this.
Jake:这个多少知道一点
Jake: I know a bit about this.
Tasha: 您真的不用争取用一下碘伏了
Tasha: You really should use some iodine.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 哈哈哈这不用争取
Lucia: Hahaha, there's no need to fight for it.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈我尽力
Jake: Hahaha, I'll try my best.
Lucia: 这真不用争取
Lucia: Really, no need to fight for it.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 您争取不用
Lucia: You really don't need to.
Jake:好争取不用
Jake: Okay, let's try not to use it.
Jake:这怎么下来
Jake: How do we get this down?
Tasha: 杨老师你把这盘弄这么脏
Tasha: Jake, you made this tray so dirty.
Jake:哎
Jake: Ah.
Jake:啊哪个盘啊对不起
Jake: Ah, which tray? Sorry.
Lucia: 烤箱盘
Lucia: The oven tray.
Tasha: 拿个纸吧
Tasha: Get some paper.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 这个干净的
Lucia: This one is clean.
Lucia: 我刚只是冲了手的时候擦了一下水
Lucia: I just wiped some water off when I washed my hands.
Lucia: 哎这为啥有
Lucia: Hey, why is there...
Lucia: 一个撒了的
Lucia: One that's spilled?
Tasha: 呃不要碰
Tasha: Uh, don't touch it.
Tasha: 等会我们还要弄进去
Tasha: We'll need to put it back in later.
Lucia: 嗯哈哈哈
Lucia: Hmm, haha.
Jake:哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈这是干净的
Tasha: Haha, this one is clean.
Shure: 一会差不多算着了
Shure: It'll be almost done soon.
Lucia: 好的好的好的
Lucia: Okay, okay, okay.
Tasha: 还还差纸还差纸
Tasha: We still need more paper.
Lucia: 擦盘子是吧
Lucia: To wipe the tray, right?
Lucia: 反正是那就用昨天肯德基还是啥
Lucia: Anyway, let's use the paper from yesterday's KFC or something.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia: 这纸这纸
Lucia: This paper, this paper...
Lucia: 为啥是这样
Lucia: Why is it like this?
Lucia: 有点太脏了
Lucia: It's a bit too dirty.
Alice:着了
Alice: It's done.
Lucia: 叮咚
Lucia: Ding dong.
Tasha: 主要这个烤盘烤箱不是借的吗
Tasha: Mainly because this oven tray isn't ours.
Alice:还有吗
Alice: Are there more?
Tasha: 啊环的时候要是烤的这么
Tasha: Ah, if we bake it like this...
Alice:在这熄火一会中毒了
Alice: If it stays here, we'll get poisoned.
Tasha: 就是都粘在这上面了
Tasha: Everything will stick to it.
Tasha: 就烤完之后就不好清理了对
Tasha: It'll be hard to clean after baking, right?
Jake:再来一个
Jake: Another one.
Jake:哎哪去了
Jake: Hey, where did it go?
Lucia: 这是几个切出来的呀
Lucia: How many pieces are cut from this?
Jake:这是一个切出来的
Jake: This is one that was cut out.
Lucia: 那还行那还行
Lucia: That's okay, that's okay.
Lucia: 我以为是俩呢
Lucia: I thought there were two of them.
Jake:哈哈哈被吃的太多了
Jake: Hahaha, it got eaten too much.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈没关系继续吃
Jake: Hahaha, no worries, keep eating.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:准备好了吗
Jake: Are you ready?
Jake:准备吃啊
Jake: Ready to eat, huh?
Tasha: OK还挺准的呢
Tasha: Okay, pretty accurate.
Tasha: 这个温度
Tasha: This temperature.
Katrina: 我要何时再回首
Katrina: When will I look back again?
Lucia: 薇薇可以吃芒果了
Lucia: Tasha, you can eat mango now.
Tasha: 不是你一个芒果就算切出这么多
Tasha: Isn't it, you cut out so much from just one mango?
Jake:是啊
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 我以为是两个切的呢
Tasha: I thought it was cut from two.
Tasha: 我还想挺不错的呢
Tasha: I think it's pretty good.
Lucia: 哈哈好
Lucia: Haha, okay.
Jake:好那那我再切一个
Jake: Alright, then I'll cut another one.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 毕竟刚才那个皮上沾了很多
Lucia: After all, the skin had a lot stuck to it earlier.
Jake:这个皮上应该也沾不少
Jake: This skin probably has a lot too.
Lucia: 如果有水果刀可以那样削着皮切
Lucia: If there's a fruit knife, you can peel and cut like that.
Lucia: 但是咱家没有
Tasha: 我们不是有个削皮刀吗
Tasha: Don't we have a peeler?
Lucia: 小心手
Lucia: Be careful with your hand.
Tasha: 好像不行
Tasha: Seems like it won't work.
Lucia: 削对
Lucia: Peel it right.
Lucia: 削一套好
Lucia: Peel a set properly.
Lucia: 削不了这个
Lucia: Can't peel this.
Lucia: 只能削红薯土豆
Lucia: Can only peel sweet potatoes and potatoes.
Jake:来试试用一些手法
Jake: Let's try using some techniques.
Tasha: 什么手法秘制
Tasha: What kind of secret technique?
Katrina: 牛逼
Katrina: Awesome.
Jake:这个就是
Jake: This is it.
Jake:慢一点
Jake: Slower.
Lucia: 兵贵神速
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha.
Tasha: 辣椒面是
Tasha: The chili powder is...
Tasha: 不知道拿去
Tasha: I don't know, take it.
Lucia: 呃外面吗
Lucia: Uh, outside?
Lucia: 也行我先给他们拿过去吧
Lucia: Alright, I'll take it to them first.
Tasha: 哎这还有个孜然
Tasha: Hey, there's some cumin here.
Tasha: 这什么东西啊芝麻
Tasha: What's this, sesame?
Lucia: 芝麻哎呀
Lucia: Sesame, oh dear.
Lucia: 拿过去吧
Lucia: Take it over.
Lucia: 看能不能用着
Lucia: See if you can use it.
Tasha: 这个地方等会要放蛋糕
Tasha: This spot is for the cake later.
Tasha: 你旁边那个架子
Tasha: The shelf next to you.
Alice:没熟
Alice: Not cooked.
Lucia: 有什么新的进展吗
Lucia: Any new progress?
Lucia: 这个辣椒面和那个芝麻
Lucia: This chili powder and sesame.
Lucia: 如果需要撒的话
Lucia: If you need to sprinkle it.
Katrina: 正在等待中哈哈
Katrina: Waiting, haha.
Shure: 就是没灯
Shure: It's just no light.
Shure: 说实话你问问杨老板
Shure: Honestly, ask Jake.
Shure: 能不能想办法给这补个光
Shure: Can we find a way to add some light?
Lucia: 啊他不是有那个影影
Lucia: Doesn't he have that shadow thingy?
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Lucia: 影楼影城
Lucia: Photo studio, cinema
Lucia: 不是影楼影棚灯吗
Lucia: Isn't it the studio lights?
Shure: 但是那个需要供电啊
Shure: But that needs electricity
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh
Lucia: 从里边拉个插板过来
Lucia: Pull an extension cord from inside
Lucia: 但是拉板不是插板可能
Lucia: But it might not be long enough
Lucia: 没那么长
Lucia: It's not that long
Katrina: 插板借插板
Katrina: Borrow an extension cord
Lucia: 我看看啊
Lucia: Let me see
Lucia: 这地方这地方的店算了
Lucia: Forget about the shop here
Tasha: 有用
Tasha: It's useful
Jake:这个接回去
Jake: This can be reattached
Lucia: 烧烤组说能整个灯不
Lucia: The barbecue group said they can get a light
Tasha: 烧烤组
Tasha: Barbecue group
Lucia: 因为外面有点暗
Lucia: Because it's a bit dark outside
Lucia: 他们现在就是在打着手电筒看
Lucia: They're using flashlights to see now
Lucia: 那个就是烤箱里面的
Lucia: Just inside the oven
Lucia: 不是烤箱烤炉里面的情况
Lucia: It's not about the oven or grill
Jake:我想想
Jake: Let me think
Lucia: 但是我感觉
Lucia: But I feel like
Lucia: 咱们这个插对一个插板也不够长
Lucia: This power strip isn't long enough
Shure: 不行煎了吧
Shure: No, let's just fry it
Jake:电线弄不出去
Jake: The wire can't reach
Lucia: 哪怕真有一个空了的话
Lucia: Even if there's an empty one
Jake:没电
Jake: No power
Tasha: 那个支架
Tasha: That stand
Tasha: 能不能把手电筒放上面会不会好点
Tasha: Can we put the flashlight on it? Would that be better?
Tasha: 就不用举着了
Tasha: Then we wouldn't have to hold it
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh
Lucia: 把那个手机固定到云台或者什么上面
Lucia: Fix the phone on the gimbal or something
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right
Lucia: 有有有有手机夹子或者啥的
Lucia: There's something that looks like it could hold a phone
Lucia: 这有个看起来有点像能夹手机的东西
Lucia: This thing here looks like it can hold a phone
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: Yeah, it can
Lucia: 但我不太确定它具体是个啥这个
Lucia: But I'm not sure what exactly it is
Tasha: 没关系哈哈
Tasha: It's okay, haha
Jake:我在乡下
Jake: I'm in the countryside
Lucia: 哎呀sorry
Jake:哦这个我来
Lucia: 这咋弄
Katrina: 可以可以
Katrina: Yes, yes
Jake:哈哈哈手机
Jake: Haha, the phone
Lucia: 哈哈哈震动模式结束了
Lucia: Haha, the vibration mode is over
Jake:哈哈关机了
Jake: Haha, it turned off
Lucia: 震动模式关机了
Lucia: The vibration mode turned off
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈你关机没电了是吧
Lucia: Hahaha, you turned it off because the battery died, right?
Lucia: 这东西是干嘛的
Lucia: What is this thing for?
Jake:是吧对
Jake: Right, exactly.
Jake:这个是
Jake: This is...
Lucia: 这个是这里
Lucia: This is here.
Lucia: 这是您之前用来想用来固定go Pro的吗
Lucia: Is this what you wanted to use to fix the GoPro?
Lucia: 还是干嘛
Lucia: Or what?
Jake:对是是这么回事
Jake: Yes, that's how it is.
Jake:但是固定手机确实不太合适
Jake: But it's really not suitable for fixing phones.
Lucia: 哦对手机带有一个那样
Lucia: Oh right, the phone comes with that.
Lucia: 就是跟自拍杆一样那种纸
Lucia: Like those selfie stick clips.
Jake:对加起来对
Jake: Yes, that's right.
Lucia: 那种夹子才行
Lucia: Those clips work.
Lucia: 这他用这边把手机夹坏了
Lucia: He broke the phone with this clamp.
Lucia: 那咋整啊
Lucia: What should we do?
Lucia: 整个绳给他绑到上面吧
Lucia: Just tie it with a string on top.
Lucia: 因为咱们的那个啥插板没那么长
Lucia: Because our power strip isn't long enough.
Jake:外边没有电哈
Jake: There's no power outside.
Katrina: 那你这个创新点
Katrina: So, about your innovation...
Lucia: 我不知道啊哈哈
Lucia: I don't know, haha.
Lucia: 你看比如说时间什么的这些
Lucia: You see, for example, things like time.
Lucia: 到了应该就可以了吧
Lucia: When it's time, it should be fine, right?
Jake:外边有插座
Jake: There's an outlet outside.
Jake:外边有插座吗
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 哦外面有插座
Lucia: Oh, there's an outlet outside.
Lucia:比较嫩
Lucia: It's quite tender.
Lucia: 里外都很香
Lucia: 我好饿呀
Tasha: 都好饿呀
Lucia: 哎小心啊
Lucia: Hey, careful!
Lucia: 吓我一跳
Lucia: You scared me!
Lucia: 哎呦妈呀
Lucia: Oh my god.
Lucia: 这刀板尽量不要放在外面
Lucia: Try not to leave the knife board outside.
Lucia: 别哪个同学碰着掉下来
Lucia: Someone might bump into it and knock it over.
Lucia: 就把人戳上了
Lucia: It could stab someone.
Lucia: 啊刚好那个锅洗好了
Lucia: Oh, just as the pot got cleaned.
Lucia: 如果要弄什么的话
Lucia: If we need to do something...
Lucia: 好香啊
Lucia: Smells so good.
Lucia: 这个擦一下是吗
Lucia: Should I wipe this?
Lucia: 嗯纸了呀在这
Lucia: Hmm, the paper is here.
Lucia: 失策
Lucia: 我们从一开始就应该买个厨房纸的
Lucia: We should've bought some kitchen paper from the start.
Tasha: 是吧
Lucia: 对
Lucia: 厨房纸的话一张就擦干了
Lucia: One sheet of kitchen paper can dry it.
Tasha: 嗯等会我们把这个奶油打一下就ok了
Lucia: 好的就OK了
Lucia: Alright, that's good.
Tasha: 然后就开始挤挤
Shure: 来吃饭好了
Shure: Come and eat, alright.
Tasha: 来吃饭
Lucia: 哦耶
Lucia: Oh yeah!
Lucia: 也行那我们一会回来再打他
Lucia: Fine, we can come back and deal with him later.
Tasha: 对擦干了就行
Lucia: 行可以可以
Lucia: Alright, alright.
Lucia: 我看一眼啊可以
Lucia: Let me take a look, okay.
Lucia: 边上再弄好了
Lucia: Fix it up on the side.
Tasha: go
Shure: 快快快不然话凉了凉了真凉了
Shure: Hurry, hurry, or it'll get cold, really cold.
Lucia: 来了来了
Lucia: Here it comes, here it comes.
Shure: 必须得整瓶啤啤
Shure: We need a whole bottle of beer.
Shure: 先吃吧真的太要凉了
Shure: Let's eat first, it's really getting cold.
Shure: 你们赶紧拿两个筷子快吃
Shure: Hurry up and grab two chopsticks and start eating.
Jake:哎来拿一串
Jake: Hey, take a skewer.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Shure: 就是再拿一个小刀什么的吧
Shure: Just grab a small knife or something.
Shure: 因为这个牌好像不是能一人一个的
Shure: Because it seems like there's not one for everyone.
Shure: 正好那个
Shure: Perfect, that...
Jake:哦哦这么回事
Jake: Oh, I see.
Jake:就总共三个是吧
Jake: So there are three in total, right?
Shure: 一二现在这顶上几个
Shure: One, two, how many are on top now?
Jake:是是吗
Jake: Is that right?
Lucia: 这里边两个吧
Lucia: 这这这个是第三个吗
Lucia: Is this the third one?
Jake:这啥呀
Jake: What's this?
Jake:你你你看看吧我咱整不明白这啥
Jake: Take a look, we can't figure out what this is.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 我这外面确实挺冷的
Lucia: It's really cold outside.
Lucia: 大家这么谦让我就先吃了
Lucia: Since everyone is being so humble, I'll go first.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我去哈哈哈
Lucia: I'm going, hahaha.
Tasha: 筷子呢啊就一个筷子m
Lucia: 啊那走
Lucia: Ah, let's go.
Lucia: 我们再搬几个筷子出来
Lucia: Let's bring out a few more pairs of chopsticks.
Jake:好咱咱咱确实要整点刀
Jake: Okay, we really need to get some knives.
Lucia: 这
Lucia: This one.
Jake:除了菜刀的一些刀
Jake: Besides some kitchen knives.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Lucia: 问题是现在这也没别的刀啊
Lucia: The problem is, there are no other knives here.
Lucia: 这也没别的刀啊
Lucia: There are no other knives here.
Lucia: 不是这也没别的筷子
Lucia: There are no more chopsticks either.
Jake:啊筷子也没了
Jake: Ah, no more chopsticks.
Alice:筷子是不是在楼上那天洗了之后
Lucia: 哦对对对
Lucia: Oh, right, right.
Shure: 拿个小刀
Shure: Get a small knife.
Jake:小刀没有小刀
Jake: No small knives.
Lucia: 你给他拿把大刀吧要不
Shure: 最好是餐刀
Shure: A dinner knife is best.
Shure: 不要不行不行
Shure: No, no, it won't work.
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
Lucia: 哎这个有了
Jake:好我拿点刀下来
Jake: Okay, I'll get some knives.
Lucia: 哦行
Lucia: 那现在有几个筷子呀
Lucia: So, how many chopsticks are there now?
Lucia: 呃就就就一个吗那就12
Lucia: Uh, just one? Then it's 12.
Lucia: 34
Lucia: 34.
Lucia: 56
Lucia: 56.
Lucia: 好就这样
Lucia: Okay, let's do it.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey.
Lucia: wait a second
Lucia: 那不是一对
Shure: 快快快帮他下
Shure: Quick, help him out.
Shure: 快帮他下
Alice:看来拿个啥东西
Alice: Seems like I should get something.
Lucia: 压一下是么
Lucia: 哦我的妈
Lucia: 这给他往里塞点
Lucia: Put some of this in for him.
Lucia: 没事我吃完不太好
Lucia: It's okay, I don't feel well after eating.
Lucia: 好了
Lucia: Done.
Lucia: 棒棒这筷子再拿回去
Lucia: Great, take these chopsticks back.
Jake:我要开切了
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Lucia: 外面放了6双
Lucia: There are six pairs outside.
Lucia: 这几双筷子先放这
Lucia: Let's leave these chopsticks here for now.
Lucia: 呃放放这吧
Lucia: Uh, put them here.
Lucia: 一会要是需要用再拿
Lucia: If we need to use them later, we can grab them.
Lucia: 嗯我刚才吃的
Lucia: Hmm, I just ate.
Tasha: 哇切的好平整呀
Tasha: Wow, it's cut so neatly.
Jake:哎呀好烫
Jake: Oh, it's so hot.
Jake:真的好烫
Jake: It's really hot.
Tasha: 烫
Tasha: Hot.
Tasha: 你放凉它
Jake:是挺烫
Jake: Yeah, it's quite hot.
Tasha: 有没有可能一下从这上面开始切
Tasha: 好吧
Jake:那还能比较
Tasha: 没办法了没关系你等会再切的上面的
Jake:那没关系它放下面一层吧
Jake:碘伏准备哎
Jake: Got the iodine ready?
Jake:哎
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:对不起了碘伏
Jake: Sorry, iodine.
Jake:用不上你了
Jake: We don't need you anymore.
Lucia: 小心手
Jake:你切的好薄呀
Jake: You cut it so thin.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Jake:这是个锅底
Jake: This is the base.
Tasha: 我不知道这一层这一层要干嘛用
Jake:这是个锅底是吧
Jake: This is the base, right?
Tasha: 尝尝吧啊不是
Jake: Try it, oh no.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 谢谢好吧
Lucia: Thanks, alright.
Tasha: 好吧那我们就扒了吃了吧
Jake:挺好吃挺好吃
Jake: It's really tasty, really tasty.
Lucia: 挺好吃
Lucia: 吃了哈哈
Tasha: 糖醋伯爵
Tasha: Sweet and sour Earl.
Lucia: 嗯真好好吃
Lucia: Mmm, it's really delicious.
Katrina: 行那就这样
Katrina: Alright, let's do it this way.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 那做两层吧还是做三层
Jake:好两两两
Jake: Alright, alright, alright.
Jake:哎三三也行
Jake: Oh, three-three is fine too.
Jake:我试试我来测一测
Jake: Let me try, I'll test it out.
Tasha: 您您
Jake:放心放心
Jake: Don't worry, don't worry.
Jake:我测一测
Jake: Let me test it.
Jake:我我测一测我测一测
Jake: I'll test it, I'll test it.
Jake:哎哎哎好好好
Jake: Okay, okay, good.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Tasha: 您测您测
Tasha: Go ahead and test it.
Jake:我先测一测
Jake: I'll test it first.
Katrina: 那还有其他的
Katrina: Are there any others?
Tasha: 好您测
Tasha: Okay, you test it.
Katrina: 还有啥问题不
Katrina: Any other problems?
Lucia: 所以说我把这底下再吃点
Lucia: 哈哈哈不着急不着急
Lucia: Haha, no rush, no rush.
Jake:哈哈哈那我慢慢测哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, I'll test it slowly then. Haha.
Tasha: 这好像就刚刚好这两层了感觉
Tasha: 2层咱们就加入芒果
Tasha: On the second layer, let's add mango.
Jake:这两层嘛
Jake: These two layers, right?
Jake:这三层嘛
Jake: Or these three layers?
Tasha: 好那你就切三层
Tasha: Okay, then you cut three layers.
Jake:我我再试一下
Jake: I'll try again.
Lucia: 不是你切着切着咱们把这吃完了
Lucia: If you keep cutting, we'll finish eating this.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 咱们已经偷偷的不为人知的吃掉了一层
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 开始了吗杨老师
Tasha: Are we starting, Mr. Yang?
Jake:开始开始开始开始开始
Jake: Start, start, start, start, start.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哎哎
Lucia: Hahaha, hey, hey.
Tasha: 哎哎你放的太窄了
Tasha: Hey, you're placing it too narrow.
Tasha: 一人干活两人帮协助
Tasha: One person works, two people help.
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Be careful.
Lucia: 小心手
Lucia: Watch your hand.
Katrina: 这是在做什么
Katrina: What are we doing here?
Jake:再切蛋糕再分层
Jake: Cutting the cake and layering it.
Katrina: 切蛋糕哇
Katrina: Cutting the cake, wow.
Lucia: 好耶
Lucia: Yay!
Jake:再来一层
Jake: One more layer.
Lucia: 这真的还够再切一层吗
Lucia: Is there really enough to cut another layer?
Tasha: 你看这一层多厚啊
Tasha: Look how thick this layer is!
Shure: 可以
Shure: It's fine.
Lucia: 再再切太薄了
Lucia: If we cut it again, it'll be too thin.
Lucia: 别别别又给最后
Lucia: No, no, no, don't do it again at the end.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 我们做出来一个pancake是吧哈哈
Lucia: We made a pancake, right? Haha
Jake:哈哈哈可以
Jake: Hahaha, sure
Katrina: 哈可以吗
Katrina: Ha, really?
Jake:吗可以
Jake: Sure
Jake:好可以吧
Jake: Alright, let's do it
Lucia: 杨老板这么自信肯定能签好
Jake: With this much confidence, you can definitely cut it well
Jake:姚老板这么自信肯定能切好
Jake:等一下我再测一下
Jake: Wait a sec, let me check again
Jake:这可以吧
Jake: Is this okay?
Lucia: 我不知道啊
Lucia: I don't know
Lucia: 你看你得问
Lucia: You see, you have to ask
Tasha: 杨老板这有一个问题
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey
Tasha: 你过来
Tasha: Come over here
Jake:我怎么了
Jake: What happened to me?
Tasha: 你看这个怎么了
Tasha: Look at this, what happened?
Jake:啊我我的几号
Jake: Ah, what's my number?
Lucia: 我的喜好
Lucia: My preference
Jake:我的4号
Jake: My number 4
Lucia: 往里弄一点
Lucia: Move it a bit inside
Tasha: 你的最后最边角的这个怎么就这么点
Lucia: 不是你不是再分配过了吗
Lucia: Didn't you already redistribute it?
Tasha: 哈哈哈这也太离谱了吧
Jake:不是不是客观
Jake: No, no, it's not objective.
Jake:不是客观规律吗
Jake: Isn't it an objective law?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈这叉子
Lucia: Hahahahaha, this fork.
Lucia: 哎呀你看这个好多呀
Lucia: Oh, look at this, there's so much.
Tasha: 哎这个怎么这么过分
Lucia: 没事没事这个预期效果和实际
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay, the expected effect and reality...
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 你这已经切开了一部分了好吗
Lucia: You already cut part of it, okay?
Jake:哈哈哈剪刀在这个左边
Jake: Hahaha, the scissors are on the left side.
Shure: 剪刀呢
Shure: Where are the scissors?
Jake:水池是左边
Jake: The water is on the left.
Tasha: ok然后那我们就
Tasha: 200克奶油20克糖
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 不是你底下那点切开了一些了
Lucia: No, you already cut a bit underneath.
Lucia: 在他那里面随便加点啥他就两种风味
Lucia: Just add something randomly inside, and it will have two flavors.
Lucia: 一半是不是我瞎说的你干嘛
Lucia: Half of it, right? I'm not making it up, why are you...
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Jake:哈我觉得合理
Jake: Ha, I think it's reasonable.
Tasha: 哇这个
Tasha: 擦干了是吧
Lucia: 我再摸摸
Lucia: Let me touch it again.
Lucia: 我我反正我刚擦
Lucia: I wiped it just now anyway.
Lucia: 我觉得是干了
Lucia: I think it's dry.
Lucia: 干了我还不在
Tasha: 行行行没事
Tasha: 你觉得要两层奶油还是一层
Jake:杨森我又来了
Jake: Jason, I'm back again.
Jake:我又行了我觉得
Jake: I think I got it again
Lucia: 我觉得你有喜欢
Lucia: I think you like it
Tasha: 偷偷用嘴
Lucia: 两层奶油的话是用多少
Lucia: How much for two layers of cream?
Lucia: 这个呀
Lucia: This one
Tasha: 200克吧你倒倒倒2
Tasha: You pour, pour, pour
Tasha: 嗯好你把糖吧倒糖这边嗯
Tasha: Okay, you pour the sugar here, hmm
Tasha: 哇正好
Tasha: 200克天才
Tasha: 天才是怎样炼成的
Jake:我还可以切一层你信不信
Jake: I can cut another layer, believe it?
Jake:我觉得我切嗨了
Jake: I think I'm on a roll
Lucia: 真的不需要看着他点吗
Lucia: Really don't need to watch him?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Tasha: 哎加加20克糖
Tasha: Hey, add 20 grams of sugar
Jake:我觉得我势不可挡啊
Jake: I feel unstoppable
Lucia: 20克糖
Lucia: 此处应该有BGM
Lucia: There should be BGM here
Lucia: 我这是不是要清零一下啊
Lucia: Should I reset this?
Tasha: 然后那个打蛋器
Tasha: 呃头
Lucia: 啊好的
Tasha: 对
Tasha: 擦干
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How is it?
Tasha: 你到底切了多少层 4层
Jake:4层
小薇 ：厉害
Jake:怎么样好
Jake: How's it looking?
小薇 ：那你去把芒果切一下吧
Tasha: Then go cut the mango.
Jake:好的
Tasha: 好我们少了一克哦不好意思多了一克
Tasha: 我刚想说少一克
Tasha: I was just about to say we're missing a gram.
Tasha: 我们主打一个低糖
Tasha: We're going for low sugar.
Tasha: 哈哈
Lucia: 等一下啊
Lucia: Hold on.
Lucia: 这这这这这啥情况
Lucia: What's going on here?
Tasha: 嗯这不是安上了吗
Lucia: 但是另外一个他好像安的时候
Lucia: But the other one, when he was setting it up...
Tasha: 还没有擦干哦
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey.
Lucia: 我还以为放那控就可以控干再擦一遍
Lucia: I thought if we let it sit, it would dry out before wiping it again.
Lucia: 哎纸呢呕在这
Lucia: Ugh, it's just stuck here now.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Lucia: 他们外面是不是可以了呀
Lucia: Is it ready outside?
Tasha: 这好聪明啊
Tasha: That's so smart.
Tasha: 这是谁想出来的想法
Tasha: Whose idea was this?
Tasha: 这样就可以了
Jake:芒果呢
Lucia: 那不是吗
Jake:哦在这了
Lucia: 外面能吃了吗
Katrina: 可以出去吧
Katrina: We can go out, right?
Lucia: 啊太好了
Lucia: Ah, great.
Lucia: 我先把这个这个给安上
Lucia: I'll just set this up first.
Jake:我也要吃嗯
Jake: I want to eat too, hmm.
Tasha: 要不要先出去吃羊排
Lucia: 好的这个你看他就是会那个啥
Lucia: Okay, see, this side fits well.
Tasha: 怎么了
Lucia: 就他这边安进去之后这边就不太好安
Lucia: But after fitting this side, the other side doesn’t fit well.
Tasha: 你看这有这个
Tasha: 要把这个对准这个
Lucia: 了
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 哦谢谢
Lucia: Oh, thanks.
Lucia: 好的那我们先那个啥吧
Lucia: Okay, then let's do that first.
Lucia: 在这在这放一下什么水哦OK好的
Lucia: Put some water here, okay, alright.
Tasha: 喝苏打水就行
Jake:吃肉了吗
Jake: Did you eat the meat?
Jake:吃肉啊吃了
Jake: Eat the meat, yeah, I did.
Lucia: 啊终于好了是吗
Lucia: Ah, finally it's ready, right?
Alice:这碳就烧没了
Alice: The charcoal is almost burnt out.
Shure: 他说能烧5-6个小时啊
Shure: He said it could burn for 5-6 hours.
Shure: 真不来点吗
Shure: 这绝对无敌
Shure: 人到齐了吗
Shure: Is everyone here?
Shure: 人到齐把香槟开了
Shure: If everyone is here, let's open the champagne.
Lucia: 等会我们坐里面
Lucia: Wait, let's sit inside.
Shure: 干羊排
Shure: 那羊排谁没吃到把那一块都吃了
Jake:我再拿个灯下来吧这边也打一个
Lucia: 嗯好
Lucia: Okay.
Shure: 而且这个室室外这圈灯不亮了
Shure: Also, the lights outside aren't working.
Shure: 你没发现吗
Shure: Didn't you notice?
Jake:哎为啥呀
Jake: Hey, why is that?
Lucia: 那我啃这个骨头了
Lucia: Then I'll gnaw on this bone.
Shure: 准备了吗
Shure: Ready?
Jake:给你打个灯
Jake: Let me light it up for you.
Lucia: 小心小心
Lucia: Careful, careful.
Jake:慢点慢点慢点
Jake: Slow down, slow down, slow down.
Jake:给你打灯给你打灯
Jake: Let me light it up for you.
Katrina: 哈哈哈笑死我了
Katrina: Hahaha, you’re killing me with laughter.
Alice:为你点灯
Alice:有点干巴
Alice: A bit dry.
Alice:有没有那种油比较多的肉啊
Alice: Do you have any meat with more fat?
Lucia: 这串看起来油都差不多的样子
Alice:买个串串吧
Alice: Let's buy a skewer.
Alice:没声啊
Alice: No sound.
Jake:跟火一样打不着
Jake: It's like the fire won't light.
Shure: 开了吧
Shure: Turn it on.
Shure: 我就不信你今天靠气纯开不开
Shure: 他奶奶个腿的
Shure: Damn it.
Jake:是不是39
Jake: Is it 39?
Jake:块钱的就不行了
Jake: If it's 39 yuan, it won't work.
Shure: 不知道啊
Shure: I don't know.
Shure: 没开过 39块钱的呀
Shure: Never tried a 39 yuan one.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 他妈啤酒平时喝一杯还他妈40呢
Shure: Beer costs 40 yuan a glass anyway.
Shure: 虽然很不优雅
Jake:但是很成功
Alice:手不会烫的
Alice: My hand won't get burned.
Lucia: 好谢谢
Lucia: 我就不客气了
Jake:对这是大徒弟和哈哈
Jake: Yes, this is the big apprentice and hahaha.
Tasha: 你来打这个奶油
Tasha: 打打就行了
Lucia: 开到5
Tasha: 对
Tasha: 一直打就行了
Jake:我继续切继续切
Jake: I’ll keep cutting, keep cutting.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Jake:好我来了
Jake: Okay, I'm coming.
Jake:看完香槟干劲十足
Jake: After seeing the champagne, I'm so motivated.
Lucia: 大概要打成什么样呀
Lucia: About how much should we beat it?
Tasha: 呃固体状就行了
Tasha: Uh, just make it solid.
Tasha: 这样是肯定不行的
Tasha: This definitely won't work.
Lucia: 固体状
Shure: 油呢
Shure: Oil?
Shure: 油呢家人们油呢
Shure: Oil, everyone, where's the oil?
Tasha: 油在这
Tasha: 一共是7个人是吧
Tasha: There are 7 people in total, right?
Jake:嗯好
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Tasha: 那就写7个桶
Tasha: Then write 7 buckets.
Jake:为什么是7个人
Jake: Why are there 7 people?
Jake:那是几个人哦
Jake: How many people are there?
Jake:6个人
Jake: 6 people.
Jake:可以是7个人一会一会会拿一个人
Jake: It could be 7 people, one person might come later.
Jake:但是他不一定什么时候来
Jake: But we don't know when they'll come.
Jake:哎垃圾桶没了
Jake: Hey, the trash can is gone.
Jake:啊垃圾桶没了
Jake: Ah, the trash can is gone.
Lucia: 看一眼这样可以吗
Lucia: 要不要再再再打一下
Lucia: Should we beat it again?
Tasha: 可以再猛抽一些
Tasha: 就这样的
Tasha: 洗手我也这样洗啊
Tasha: I wash my hands like this too.
Lucia: 现在呢我感觉好像
Lucia: Now, I feel like...
Lucia: 对你看一眼
Lucia: Yeah, take a look.
Tasha: 我信你
Lucia: 把这个甩一下可以了吗
Lucia: Shake this, is that okay?
Lucia: 嗯要在
Tasha: 可以可以
Tasha: 然后你看刚刚那样把这个奶油甩出来
Tasha: 然后把
Tasha: 用刮刀把它刮到那个裱花嘴里面
Lucia: 好的剩下这个
Lucia: Okay, the rest...
Lucia: 这盘是干净的吧
Lucia: This plate is clean, right?
Lucia: 那我先在这放一下
Lucia: I'll put it here for now.
Lucia: i think yes
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Tasha: 如果你有4只手的话会不会变成猴子
Tasha: If you had four hands, would you turn into a monkey?
Lucia: 那个刮刀在哪里
Lucia: Where's the spatula?
Lucia: 是不是在这边呀
Lucia: Is it over here?
Tasha: 刮刀嗯刮刀刮刀刮刀
Lucia: 哈哈哈竟然在这里
Lucia: Haha, it's actually here.
Lucia: 我要把它放到
Lucia: I'm going to put it...
Lucia: 放到哪
Tasha: 也要把它洗干净擦干
Lucia: 嗯然后
Tasha: 然后放到裱花袋里呃
Tasha: 裱花嘴在哪里呢
Tasha: 这个未解之谜
Tasha: 我们仍未知道纳粹的裱花嘴在哪里
Lucia: 可以那但是就是那
Lucia: Okay, but that's...
Lucia: 需要一个人撑一下这个小花袋
Lucia: Need someone to hold this piping bag.
Tasha: OK我来了
Tasha: OK, I'm coming.
Tasha: 我把草莓扒完
Tasha: I'll finish peeling the strawberries.
Lucia: 好嘞
Lucia: Got it.
Jake:对啊那个裱花嘴呢
Jake: Yeah, where's the piping tip?
Tasha: 裱花嘴你到底洗到哪里
Tasha: Where did you wash the piping tip?
Jake:我应该放在某一个容器里爆
Jake: I should have put it in a container to explode.
Lucia: 没事至少我们还有裱花袋
Lucia: It's okay, at least we still have the piping bag.
Lucia: 有吧哦在这
Lucia: There it is, oh, here it is.
Lucia: 别我刚话音话音未落
Lucia: Don't, I just said that.
Lucia: 他发现他还找不着
Lucia: He found it, but he still can't find it.
Lucia: 那就比较搞笑了
Lucia: That's pretty funny.
Lucia: 对对对这里
Lucia: Yes, yes, here.
Tasha: 裱花袋在哪里
Tasha: 哦在这
Tasha: 要一个刀剪刀
Lucia: 咱们的剪刀首先它不知道在哪里
Lucia: First of all, our scissors, we don't know where they are.
Lucia: 其次它好像是用来剪快递的哈哈哈
Lucia: Second, they seem to be used for cutting packages, hahaha.
Jake:嗯外边有剪刀
Jake: Hmm, there are scissors outside.
Jake:外边是切肉的
Jake: Outside ones are for cutting meat.
Tasha: 外面那个已经剪肉了
Lucia: The ones outside have already cut meat.
Jake:嗯肉也
Jake: Hmm, meat too.
Tasha: 疯了能用
Jake:那切一下
Tasha: 切不开我来切
Lucia: Can't cut, let me cut.
Jake:我来切我来切
Jake: Let me cut, let me cut.
Lucia: 让对让我来切
Lucia: Yes, let me cut.
Tasha: 牛啊
Jake:我可以来
Jake: I can do it.
Jake:切哪
Tasha: 切这
Jake:切这
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: 牛啊
Lucia: 哇啊
Jake:我还没用尽呢哎
Jake: I haven't used all my strength yet.
Lucia: 牛啊
Lucia: Awesome.
Lucia: 怎么
Lucia: How...
Jake:没我刚刚还
Jake: No, I just...
Jake:我刚刚还没用尽呢
Jake: I hadn't finished yet.
Jake:怎么就开了
Jake: How did it start?
Jake:不愧是一代刀神
Lucia: 牛啊
Lucia: Impressive.
Tasha: 转世
Jake:重生转世
Tasha: 重生之我是小富贵
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 呃哈哈
Jake:能不能说点好的哈哈
Jake: Can we say something nice, haha.
Tasha: 我再想想
Tasha: 重生之我是米其林主厨
Jake:好这个可以
Jake: Okay, that's good.
Tasha: 怎么小福贵
Tasha: 你不愿意
Jake:呃好吧
Jake: Uh, fine.
Lucia: 里面的这个茶给人一种香草籽的感觉
Lucia: This tea inside gives a vanilla bean vibe.
Tasha: 伯爵茶
Lucia: 是的
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 天然香草的话就会有香草籽
Lucia: If it's natural vanilla, there'd be vanilla seeds.
Lucia: 先刮刮看
Lucia: Let's scrape it first.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 这还有一点把它弄下来
Lucia: There's still some here, let's get it off.
Jake:第3个Mango
Jake: Third one, Mango.
Lucia: 不错转化率怎么样
Lucia: Not bad, how's the conversion rate?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈没有我开玩笑的啦
Lucia: Hahaha, I'm just kidding.
Jake:哈哈哈可以称一称
Jake: Hahaha, we can weigh it.
Jake:来称称一称吧
Jake: Let's weigh it.
Jake:称一称称一称称一称
Jake: Weigh it, weigh it, weigh it.
Jake:有称吗在用是吧
Jake: Is there a scale? Are you using it?
Tasha: 这有秤
Jake:来来来不是可以
Jake: Come on, that's fine.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Tasha: 转化率怎么样了
Tasha: 我们看看
Tasha: 那个盒子制作的话是400克还是500克的
Tasha: Is that box made with 400 grams or 500 grams?
Lucia: 这这上面还有草莓
Lucia: There's still strawberries on this.
Jake:草莓没有
Jake: No strawberries.
Tasha: 草莓还有糖怎么办
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:我们一会加上去
Jake: We'll add it later.
Tasha: 好开始
Tasha: 这是一个92克的芒果好行
Tasha: This is a 92-gram mango, okay.
Jake:好行
Jake: Okay, fine.
Jake:先就放这吧
Jake: Just leave it here.
Tasha: 行放这吧
Tasha: 再切一个就行了
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:一个92克的芒果
Jake: A 92-gram mango.
Lucia: 这剩下的芒果可以吃了对吧哈哈哈
Lucia: We can eat the remaining mango, right? Hahaha.
Tasha: 是的
Lucia: 蹑手蹑脚的靠近
Lucia: Sneak closer.
Jake:好有两个好的
Jake: Okay, two good ones.
Tasha: 哎呀我天啊
Jake:蚝油
Tasha: 一代厨神也有失误的时候大家都能理解
Tasha: 哇越发熟练了
Lucia: 不错熟能生巧啊
Lucia: Not bad, practice makes perfect.
Tasha: 你看他夸一夸
Lucia: Look at him praising it.
Jake:哈哈哈马上菜刀就掉了
Jake: Hahaha, the kitchen knife will drop soon.
Tasha: 只要一群女生围在他旁边夸他
Tasha: As long as there are a group of girls praising him around.
Tasha: 他就会啊哈哈
Tasha: He will be like, hahaha.
Jake:我就会什么他就会怎么
Jake: What will I do, what will he do?
Lucia: 哈这什么原话
Lucia: Huh, what’s the original saying?
Jake:菜刀就会掉了
Jake: The kitchen knife will drop.
Tasha: 我也不记得反正就这个意思
Tasha: 好厉害啊
Tasha: So impressive.
Tasha: 衣服好好看呀
Tasha: 店里面衣服怎么这么好看
Tasha: The clothes in the store are so beautiful.
Tasha: 能便宜点吗
Lucia: Can it be cheaper?
Tasha: 再便宜点
Lucia: Even cheaper.
Tasha: 对我好像我好像
Lucia: I feel like I...
Lucia: 我好像刷到过这个类似的梗
Lucia: I think I've seen this joke before.
Jake:烤完了
Shure: 没有没有了哈哈哈
Shure: No, no more, hahaha.
Jake:什么什么叫没有了
Jake: What do you mean no more?
Lucia: 什么没有了
Lucia: What no more?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:什么叫没有了烤完了
Jake: What do you mean no more, finished the exam?
Shure: 也不是
Shure: Not really.
Tasha: 吃的没有了是吧
Tasha: 是不
Tasha: 烧烤料拿出去了吗
Lucia: 嗯我拿了那个辣椒粉和那个芝麻
Lucia: Hmm, I got the chili powder and sesame.
Lucia: 都在外面
Lucia: They're all outside.
Lucia: 你看还有啥别的
Lucia: Look if there's anything else.
Shure: 有一个袋装的那个
Shure: There is a bagged one.
Lucia: 袋
Lucia: 您的盘子已经准备好了
Lucia: Your plate is ready.
Jake:好的这是什么
Jake: Okay, what is this?
Jake:这是半年总结
Jake: This is the mid-year summary.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:刚刚是多少单的那个数字 92
Jake: What was the number of orders just now? 92.
Lucia: 92好像
Lucia: 92, I think.
Lucia: 不过考虑到皮和那个核
Lucia: But considering the skin and core...
Lucia: 我们还可以有一些
Lucia: We can still have some.
Jake:不用考虑
Jake: No need to consider.
Lucia: 我们可以有一些depreciation了哈
Lucia: We can have some depreciation, huh?
Jake:好哈哈哈自信一点
Jake: Okay, hahaha, be more confident.
Jake:不不要考虑
Jake: No, don't consider it.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Jake:哈哈哈就要8%
Jake: Hahaha, just 8%.
Lucia: 哈不要考虑
Lucia: Ha, don't consider it.
Lucia: 你不是违背那个什么
Lucia: Aren't you violating something?
Lucia: 热力学第一定律了吗
Lucia: The first law of thermodynamics?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake:牛顿要出来了是吧
Jake: Newton is coming out, right?
Lucia: 热力学第一定律是谁发现的
Lucia: Who discovered the first law of thermodynamics?
Jake:那是什么东西
Jake: What is that?
Jake:牛顿
Jake: Newton.
Lucia: 管他呢反正都是牛嘴
Lucia: Whatever, it's all Newton's stuff.
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 他们外面好了吗
Lucia: Are they done outside?
Lucia: 好饿哦他们
Lucia: They're so hungry.
Jake:是啊好饿
Jake: Yeah, so hungry.
Lucia: 让我再观摩一下这个
Lucia: Let me observe this again.
Jake:我的四号
Lucia: 对
Jake:我的四号小蛋糕
Lucia: 你看看
Tasha: 它好可怜
Lucia: 他好少啊
Tasha: 一开始就跟他说了
Tasha: Told him at the beginning.
Tasha: 杨老师不患寡而患不均哈哈哈
Tasha: Mr. Yang worries about inequality, not scarcity, haha.
Jake:怎么办一会第一个吃他吧
Jake: What to do, let him eat first.
Jake:对他好一点
Jake: Treat him better.
Tasha: 好吧没事了OK
Lucia: 怀疑你在阐述什么奇怪的定律
Lucia: I suspect you're explaining some weird law.
Lucia: 比如说马太效应什么的
Lucia: Like the Matthew effect or something.
Jake:哦是这个还行吧
Jake: Oh, this one's okay.
Jake:看测一下
Jake: Check it out.
Lucia: 怎么测呢
Lucia: How do you check?
Tasha: 我们一看归零了啊哎
Tasha: 哦就这样就行了
Tasha: Oh, that's fine.
Tasha: 因为我们没有51
Tasha: Because we don't have 051.
Jake:哦过半了好好
Jake: Oh, more than half, good, good.
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: Alright, alright.
Lucia: 还不错
Lucia: Not bad.
Lucia: 因为本身这些核和皮就有一些
Lucia: Because these pits and skins naturally have some...
Jake:好的
Jake:我现在在忙切
Jake: I'm busy cutting now.
Lucia: 嗯糖粉
Lucia: Hmm, powdered sugar.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 哎这个这个是
Lucia: Oh, this, this is...
Tasha: 这两个也要
Tasha: 来吧
Jake:去哪
Jake: Where are you going?
Lucia: 这俩是干净的吗
Lucia: Are these two clean?
Lucia: 要冲冲吗还是
Lucia: Do we need to rinse them or...
Tasha: 呃冲一冲用水擦一下也行
Lucia: 行反正好几天没用了
Lucia: It's been a few days since they were last used anyway.
Shure: 我油还回来了吗
Shure: Did my oil get returned?
Shure: 没有是吗
Shure: No, it didn't?
Shure: 油没还回来
Shure: The oil wasn't returned.
Tasha: 就在那个商考架旁边
Tasha: It's right next to the commercial rack.
Lucia: 呦妈呀不好意思
Tasha: 杨老师
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Tasha: 您来
Jake:我在干嘛
Jake: What am I doing?
Tasha: 你干嘛呢在偷吃是吧
Tasha: What are you doing, sneaking food, right?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:我没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake:我要把这一点对
Jake: I just need to do this.
Lucia: 他提高转化率
Lucia: He increases the conversion rate.
Jake:用一些用一些细枝末节的手段
Jake: Using some minor methods.
Jake:哈哈哈在哪
Jake: Hahaha, where is it?
Tasha: 来吧杨老师
Jake:嗯增加1.1%
Jake: Hmm, increased by 1.1%.
Tasha: 杨老师您切的
Lucia: Teacher Yao, the way you cut...
Tasha: 薄如蝉哈哈哈
Jake:哈哈哈这不是适合铺在上面吗
Jake: Hahaha, isn't this perfect for laying on top?
Lucia: 薄如蝉哈哈哈
Lucia: As thin as a cicada's wing, hahaha
Tasha: 来吧杨老师
Jake:好
Lucia: Come on
Jake:我要干嘛
Jake: What should I do?
Tasha: 您就坐在这里
Jake:我坐在这里
Jake: I sit here
Jake:你们也坐
Jake: You guys sit too
Jake:来我们一起坐
Jake: Come on, let's sit together
Tasha: 怎么一起坐
Tasha: How do we sit together?
Jake:就哈哈确实
Jake: Just haha, indeed
Lucia: 只有两个凳子呢哈哈哈
Lucia: There are only two stools, hahaha
Jake:那我先坐
Jake: Then I'll sit first
Jake:然后呢
Jake: And then?
Lucia: 两凳子都归你了
Lucia: Both stools are yours
Jake:哈哈哈我分分
Jake: Hahaha, I'll split them
Lucia: 坐在飞机上占用边的座位
Lucia: Sit on the plane and take up the aisle seat
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha, oh
Jake:那我得躺着坐
Jake: Then I have to lie down and sit
Jake:然后呢
Jake: And then?
Tasha: 这是什么
Jake:啊我会我会我会我会
Jake: Ah, I can, I can, I can
Jake:来给我我会
Jake: Come on, give it to me, I can do it
Tasha: 等等等等真的你不会
Tasha: Wait, wait, wait, you really can't
Tasha: 好了然后你挤一圈
Jake:好我挤一圈
Jake: Okay, I'll squeeze around
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Tasha: 然后你把它挤铺平吧
Jake:到我了
Jake: It's my turn.
Tasha: 然后刮刀就把它刮平
Shure: 这回服务到位吗
Shure: Is the service good this time?
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Tasha: 这个肉这个肉熟了吗
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Shure: 我试吃一个
Lucia: 要等他把这都解完了我才能刮是吗
Lucia: Do I have to wait for him to finish all of these before I can scratch?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:是熟了吗
Jake: Are they well-cooked?
Tasha: 他拿出来了说明没熟我觉得
Tasha: He took them out, so I think they're not well-cooked.
Lucia: 啊那咱刚吃的呢
Lucia: Ah, what about the ones we just ate?
Lucia: 不知道那个感觉还行吧
Lucia: I don't know, the taste was okay, right?
Jake:那个感觉还行吧
Jake: The taste was okay, right?
Lucia: 没事反正是羊肉牛肉没有寄生虫
Lucia: It's fine, lamb and beef don't have parasites anyway.
Jake:嗯对没错
Jake: Yeah, that's right.
Lucia: 怎么刮要不你示范一下
Lucia: How to scratch? Why don't you demonstrate?
Tasha: 要不然直接加芒果吧
Lucia: 啊哈哈哈
Lucia: Ah hahaha.
Tasha: 突然觉得我手洗过了
Lucia: 没事反正咱一直在这做饭呢
Jake:对就是
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake:卫生等级a
Jake: Hygiene grade A.
Jake:这边是怎么分呢
Jake: How is it rated here?
Jake:卫生等级哦OK
Jake: Hygiene grade, oh OK.
Lucia: 好像是有a b c啊
Lucia: Seems like there's A, B, C.
Lucia: 但是一般来说好像也无人在意
Lucia: But generally, no one really cares.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Jake:现在好了
Jake: It's fine now.
Shure: 杨老板你就吃吧
Shure: Jake, just eat it.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Tasha: 好了杨老板第二惨
Shure: 你就闭着眼睛吃吧
Shure: Just eat with your eyes closed.
Shure: 一定要闭眼 的是吧
Tasha: 他就像那个来上学的diy
Tasha: He's like the guy who comes to DIY class.
Tasha: 蛋糕手工课
Tasha: Cake crafting class.
Shure: 是吧
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Shure: 没问题吧
Shure: No problem, right?
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Shure: 还活着哈哈
Shure: Still alive, haha.
Shure: 没问题这还有一个
Shure: No problem, there's still one more.
Jake:还活着
Jake: Still alive.
Shure: 这绝对熟了哈哈
Shure: This one's definitely cooked, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈啥
Jake: Hahaha, what?
Lucia: 哈哈哈啊谢谢
Lucia: Hahaha, thank you.
Shure: 哈没有一个人敢自己放手里吃是吧
Shure: Haha, no one dares to eat it with their hands, right?
Tasha: 没有啊我们一人一半
Jake:意思这绝对熟啊
Jake: Meaning this one's definitely cooked.
Tasha: 我们到时候把最上面一层抹一下就行好看
Tasha: We'll just smooth the top layer and it will look good.
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Okay.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: 我我说你上那个来上DIY手工课了
Tasha: I said you came here for a DIY crafting class.
Tasha: 哎还剩这么多奶油呢
Tasha: Hey, there's still so much cream left.
Tasha: 多挤点没事
Tasha: Squeeze more, it's fine.
Jake:没事
Jake: It's fine.
Lucia: 那要不然一会直接用来弄那个纸杯蛋
Lucia: Why don't we use it for the cupcakes later?
Tasha: 然后然后你把这个边边一圈再挤一下
Tasha: Then, then squeeze around the edges again.
Tasha: 加高一下他
Tasha: Make it taller.
Tasha: 对然后我们
Tasha: 加巧克力豆
Jake:我来没手了
Jake: I'll do it, no hands left.
Jake:哎我去厉害
Jake: Oh wow, impressive.
Lucia: 小心别洒了
Lucia: 我好饿
Lucia: I'm so hungry.
Lucia: 哈哈哈看着他觉得好想吃
Lucia: Haha, just looking at it makes me want to eat.
Jake:跟杜雅拿个凳子来
Jake: Go grab a chair from Doya.
Lucia: 嗯没事没事我这样就行了
Lucia: No, it’s fine. I can manage like this.
Katrina: 这个
Katrina: This one...
Jake:有有有我屋里多的很
Jake: Yeah, yeah, I’ve got plenty in my room.
Lucia: 对乖
Lucia: Alright, good.
Lucia: 哦那也行
Lucia: Oh, that works too.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 原来是某些人私藏了
Lucia: So someone was hiding it all along.
Jake:对我的黑工办公室
Jake: Yeah, in my secret office.
Lucia: 那我就先鸠占鹊巢了
Lucia: Well, I’ll just make myself at home then.
Tasha: OK
Lucia: 掉一个
Lucia: 鸠占鹊巢
Lucia: 给您坐C位坐C位
Jake:我要干嘛
Jake: What should I do?
Tasha: 您再起还剩这么多奶油吗
Tasha: Do you still have this much cream?
Jake:好来了
Jake: Alright, coming.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哎你俩这个时候你来
Lucia: Hahaha, why are you here now?
Tasha: 哎你这怎么放啊
Tasha: Hey, how do you place this?
Jake:有救
Jake: There’s hope.
Lucia: 就能把它再弄上去吗
Lucia: Can you put it back on?
Tasha: 嗯
Lucia: 是这是是这样吗
Lucia: Is this how it’s done?
Tasha: 对哎
Lucia: 那就是其实只用一个包也行对吧
Lucia: So, actually, one bag would be enough, right?
Jake:对啊
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 对好吧这蛋糕太小了
Lucia: 没没必要那么大的
Lucia: There's no need for it to be that big.
Jake:我觉得我怎么挤都没关系对吧
Jake: I think it doesn't matter how I squeeze, right?
Tasha: 对但是你这不是增加人家工作量
Tasha: Yeah, but you're just increasing their workload.
Tasha: 你再把边边一圈加高一下
Tasha: Raise the edges a bit higher.
Lucia: 等一下这个上面回粘很多
Jake:没事给下一层吧
Jake: It's fine, give it to the next layer.
Jake:没了是吧
Jake: Is it all gone?
Lucia: 也行反正反正会用到
Lucia: It's okay, we'll still use it anyway.
Tasha: 再挤一圈
Jake:我还挤一圈
Tasha: 对
Jake:对好再补一补
Jake: Right, let's add some more.
Lucia: 我先把这个大点的板放回去
Jake:哎呀没事
Jake: Oh well, it's fine.
Lucia: 哎呦不好意思
Jake:好玩好玩好玩好玩好玩
Jake: Fun, fun, fun, fun, fun.
Jake:好玩好玩好玩
Jake: Fun, fun, fun.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh my.
Tasha: 然后把所有的芒果都用完在这一层
Jake:真的这么多
Jake: Really, that much?
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh wow.
Lucia: 我们
Lucia: We...
Lucia: 这个最后会不会高超过他的长宽啊
Lucia: Will it end up being taller than its width?
Tasha: 啊什么东西
Tasha: Huh? What is this?
Lucia: 就是这个
Lucia: This.
Lucia: 这个圆柱
Lucia: This cylinder.
Lucia: 体的h超过他的直径哈哈哈
Lucia: The height surpasses its diameter, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈OK就是他是一个长的
Jake: Hahaha, okay, so it's a tall one.
Jake:不是一个扁的
Jake: Not a flat one.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:一个高个小蛋糕对
Jake: A tall, small cake, right.
Lucia:  对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 那样就会有点不太好切
Lucia: That way, it would be a bit hard to cut.
Lucia: 就是切了之后就容易倒
Lucia: It just falls over easily after you cut it.
Lucia: 没事管他呢
Jake:这汉堡挺好哈哈哈
Jake: This burger is pretty good, hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈救命
Lucia: Hahaha, help me!
Lucia: 这边稍微有点这边稍微有点矮
Lucia: This side is a bit lower.
Lucia: 就是这边高一点这边矮一点
Lucia: This side is higher, and this side is lower.
Lucia: 我给他刮一下把这拖上去
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha.
Alice:给
Alice: Here.
Jake:不是主要这个表面很像汉堡
Jake: It's mainly because the surface looks like a burger.
Jake:要点肉我要
Jake: I need some meat.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈甜
Lucia: Hahaha, sweet.
Lucia: 都是咸的你不觉得很奇怪吗
Lucia: It's all salty, don't you think it's weird?
Jake:我要干嘛我要干嘛
Jake: What should I do, what should I do?
Tasha: 再挤一圈
Jake:再挤一圈
Tasha: 哇这一圈就是要平整
Jake:对这个应该就是区别于汉堡的
Jake: Yeah, this should be what differentiates it from a burger.
Jake:最重要的一层对
Jake: The most important layer, yes.
Alice:差不多了
Alice: It's almost done.
Lucia: 这这外围
Lucia: This, this outer part...
Jake:我等会我捋一捋我
Jake: Wait, let me think about it...
Lucia: 这个你小心别把他吊在这个上面
Lucia: Be careful not to hang it on this.
Jake:捋一捋
Jake: Let me think...